hello everyone and welcome to the 1971
semi-final match between Bobby Fischer
and bent Larsen now as you've seen in my
previous couple of videos in the Bobby
Fischer series the quarterfinal match in
1971 was against mark tamaño which Bobby
Fischer pretty much destroyed six to
zero although as you've seen if you've
watched thoroughly every one of my
videos it wasn't really like like he
just came there and destroyed mark time
on of every game was a really a close
call and in most of the games that that
were really competitive it was actually
taimanov who had the the upper hand but
in the end you know a Fischer prevailed
so here at Fischer faces bent Larsen now
what what to say about this match let's
let's first see how the other matches in
the quarterfinals went so here we have
all of all of the matches as we've said
Fischer time on off ended ended after
six games with the official winning at
six six to zero
Larsen versus Ullman and after nine
games the match ended five and a half
three and a half and here we have a
match that was played in Seville Tigran
Petrosian versus Robert Huebner and the
match ended after seven games and the
result being four two three four Tigran
Petrosian but as you as you can see here
the first six games were drawn and then
the seventh game and with a win for
Tigran Petrosian and then as you see
here the match was resigned prematurely
so after only losing one game
Robert Huebner resigned to the game and
I have no idea why that happened so you
might think ok this Hagen matter dude he
has a chess channel of course his
knowledge is vast but not that fast and
I'm very interested why this happened it
might be a really simple and dull answer
but as I've never heard of this
we shall definitely get back to this all
of the matches when we when we finish
the Bobby Fischer series maybe not
immediately but at some point and of
course Viktor Korchnoi defeated f'ing
Geller five and a half to three and a
half the match ended after 88 games so
here like we said Fisher Fisher versus
Larsson
we do have a very interesting photo here
this here is a four
of the temple view of college in Denver
Colorado so it's from a vintage postcard
it doesn't look like this today of
course but it's the venue where the
match took place those of you who are
perhaps from Denver Colorado you might
recognize it as this is the way it looks
today today it's known as the Denver
School of Arts so if you are from Denver
perhaps you know yeah you know this
place and here we also have a nice view
of the playing hall so this is what
Fisher and Larson would see from the
stage when they looked at away from the
board and check out what the audience
was doing and those of those people who
have seen this playing hall in 1971 say
that it looks exactly the same today in
2018 so also a very nice a very nice
photo here here we have it's not the
greatest of photos but today we have
Bobby Fischer on the left holding a
white bone and the black bone where
Larson is picking which color he will
have which pieces color he will have in
the first game and here we have a photo
of just before the game the game one
started on the wall you can see temple
Buell College as we've seen in the
vintage postcard so what more can we say
about this match as it is the first game
so we should definitely say something
about it
and now the the Soviets and the marked
amount of probably along with the so
it's really under underestimated Fisher
in the first match why did they do this
well there was this idea that Fisher was
afraid of losing you games it might have
something to do with the fact that
Fisher refused to play the 1958 US
Championship because he said that he was
afraid he will not win the tournament
because there are so few players there
and if he loses the one or two games
like by an accident as he put it him he
might not win the tournament and he
wasn't afraid of not he wasn't afraid of
losing but he didn't want the win in a
tournament you know be decided by by you
know a small lack of judgment for
example in one game and another player
could have an excellent tournament and
then win the tournament it was simply a
matter of a chess professional who was
really used to
to winning tournaments and this is the
case with Fischer and both with Larsen
both of them as they are from the United
States you know they weren't like they
had no other careers they were chess
players and they earned a living playing
chess so - both of them winning the well
not winning but qualifying in the palm
of America Interzone winning the
candidates and India and winning the
World Chess Championship means really a
lot because it's a it's not that big of
a difference if you're like really
really successful chess player a
grandmaster really famous and that you
are a world champion so in in terms of
strength the difference isn't all that
great but in terms of the money you will
make the differences enormous so you
know for either of them who loses this
match you will have to go back to
chasing tournaments winning prizes
holding simultaneous exhibitions you
know to make a living as Fischer said
Fischer made like $10,000 for his book
Bobby Fischer teaches chess and he makes
half of what my 60 memorable games makes
and also he receives a three hundred
dollars per month for chess count he
he's doing for a youth chess magazine so
that's I mean that is a lot of money
when you you know look at it like that
but you know he only received the
$10,000 once and now he basically makes
a living with what he earns and what he
wins and there there is a it's been said
that he received $500 for every victory
he achieved against mark Damon off but
he did not receive anything for a draw
so Fischer was used his entire life to
playing until the the barre Kings so
even if the position was drawn he would
play it out hoping you know he would
make the strongest moves forever and
that his opponent wouldn't make the
strongest moves and in the end win the
game something Magnus calls and is also
known for today but in those days you
really had to do it if you wanted to
make a living out of chess so also an
ideas the Soviets might have
underestimated is that Fischer pretty
much grew up with the Russian chess
literature he learned that the Russian
language used the Russian chess books
everything the Russian knew and he could
get his hands on
he knew that you know he even learned
Spanish language he learned the Serbian
language anything he could use to get
ahead in chess and you know they say
that whenever you would ask Fischer for
an autograph he would sometimes even
write write his name in Russian swim
a lot of interesting things to say about
this match but as we don't want to make
the video last forever
I will put a link in the description
below it will be the first thing you
will see I suggest you click on it if
you have time read the entire article
before we start the game if not perhaps
you can do it later or maybe after the
game but there are a lot of useful
useful facts there one such example is
that after the main match would mark the
amount of fish did spend some time with
Amano and they did have a conversation
Fischer also had a nice conversation
with Timon of second ball Asif and
Fischer said that blush of actually knew
more Bobby Fischer games by heart than
Bobby Fischer himself have Fischer
tested him he said what what what moves
I played in that game 13 years ago and
then Bellagio we knew it all by heart so
III do suggest you read it but you know
if you don't have the time then you will
have to settle for the game I guess so
ok Fischer has the white pieces and he
opens would will know what Bobby
Fischer's official opens with with the
white pieces he opens with E 4 and we
have e 6 by bent Larsen the Great Dane
opt for the French defense against Bobby
which is pretty much to be expected as
the French defense is something Fischer
had the hardest time dealing with but
when he was younger this is not the
young Bobby Fischer anymore so ok d4 d5
Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 the
vinegar variation C 5 we have nine three
seven a3 now challenging the Bishop
Bishop captures pawn captures and now c5
so here we have a lot of good ideas
where you can go for Queen G for
threatening the g7 pawn Knight to f3 is
also an idea and the third variation
often played was a four it's okay knight
b c6 Knight to f3
William Bishop to d7 and now comes the
bishop
to d3 Queen to c7 for castles we have c4
often you might ask yourself is this a
good move to play or not
well it depends what kind of positions
you enjoy playing when the pawn is on c5
you're still engaged in the in the
battle for for the center while I push
c4 you do remove the bishop to a less
less active Square but now the center
becomes more static and you will have to
challenge it at some point with f6 okay
f6
we have rook to e1 and here Larson has a
couple of good options he can exchange F
capture 75 he could Castle which seems
to be the safest choice but instead he
goes for Knight to g6 he thinks that
Fischer will now have to either capture
or add further protection which is not
all that easy to do or simply continue
developing Ruby won or something but
here Fischer finds a nice idea he wants
to grab the initiative he decides to
sacrifice upon and he plays Bishop to a3
as you can see the bishop is slicing all
the way here so a king sized castle will
no longer be possible for Larson but he
will win a pawn here so k-f captures on
e5 d captures night C captures on d5
Knight captures any five and nine
chapters on e5 so Larsson did one upon
but now comes Queen to d4 so such a
beautiful centralizing move with the
Queen Queen d4 for the price of one pawn
is of course almost always worth it
now also possible was a bishop to h5
Bishop to h5 check of course g6 and only
now Queen before with a double attack on
the night the night here is pinned of
course as the Queen is attacking the
rook on h8 but now after pawn captures
rook captures black can go for a
queenside castle and Fisher Fisher
thought that this would have been better
better for for black than the the option
he chose so okay 95 Fisher went for
Queen to b4 immediately and now comes
Knight back to g6
if you decided to go for something like
castles here sorry not castles here but
after Knights to g6 if you decided
instead of worship to h5 to go for Queen
captures on Jesus
this would be met with a queen-sized
castle and then after Queen returns to
be for attacking the a7 pawn king to b8
and okay
black gave back the pawn and he managed
to Castle queenside he did you know grab
some safety and the wild fish would have
the semi open B file for attack Larsson
would also have the G file for attack
it's okay after an IG six fish replace
Bishop to h5 pinning the knight on g6
and here we have pink to f7 it's very
interesting I mean you could go for a
queen set her castle here and allow
Queen captures on a seven for example b6
Queen eight check Queen to be it
captures captures and then for example
a5 and it would be it would be very
unpleasant here B captures an 85 now
Bishop to d6 check King b7 and now Luke
captures the other rook is ready to come
to B 1 it would be very hard for black
to defend this and also there are all
sorts of tricks here into position Queen
to h4 as the knight is pinned with the
threat of Queen e7 checkmate the ideas
are like a bunch of characters on g6
capturing the rock on a trade so Larsson
really has to take a lot into
considerate consideration here King to
f7 was played he decided he will not go
to the Queen side but rather he wants to
protect everything we have a beautiful
move by Fischer here F for the strongest
move in the position threatening f5 if
the e-file is opened then rook to e7
will be deadly again the night and g6 is
pinned so rook ht8 and now okay opening
up DF file rook to e7 will no longer be
possible but still f5 is the strongest
move into position and Fischer plays it
so we have f5 again the knight is pinned
at what do you do here eek a presen f5
the strongest move and then out comes
Queen captures on b5 this is what check
you can't block this check if you play
Bishop to e6 then you get rook captures
on e6 rook captures and Dena comes Queen
captures on f5 rook to f6 and Queen to
d5 check again
rook to e6 and now rope to f1 check as
the bishop is still slicing all the way
here all through the dark squares you
would have to move the King
you lose the rook and it's game over
so after hinted Queen d5 King to f6 was
played so okay
now your king is on f6 it's only moved
20 and it's hard to hard to imagine that
a pawn was was worth bringing your king
to f6 but it seems the Larson has
everything figured out as you'll see
here
Bishop to f3 was played by Fisher with a
double attack against the b7 pawn but a
Fischer's preparation was Bishop to d6
here with an attack on the Queen but it
was a bit better to play Bishop to d6
before actually going for Bishop to f3
Fisher went Bishop to f3 first and this
allows this 95 counter now this Bishop
to d6 move isn't isn't so great if
Bishop to d6 moves play the sooner then
95 would wouldn't have been an option
but okay Queen d4 Fischer pins the
knight pink to g6 Larson on pins and
this is the greatest moment in game
number 1 which was you know discussed
for for over 50 years because it's so
beautiful there isn't really a good I
mean a clear way to proceed in this
position but Fischer saw so so so many
moves into the future and only later
will Larson figure out just just how
much pressure outclassed him in this
game so it was in this it was in this
position that Fischer played rook
captures on e5 and there is a reason I I
asked I didn't ask you to pause the
video and find rook characters on e5
because if you haven't seen this game
chances are okay you would most likely
find rook captures on e5 but you
wouldn't understand what it meant
because it's it's really really you'll
just have to see what I mean
Queen captures on e5 okay Fischer
sacrifice the exchange let's let's see
what why he did it
Queen captures on d7 this is the move
Larson thought wasn't possible because
now okay you did grab two pieces for the
rook but how do you how do you counter
rook a to d8
Queen III check isn't all that great of
course you're not going to go to h1 and
allow Queen to e1 which will leave the
but you will simply King to f1 and now
it's it's all it's playable
so instead after Queen to d7 immediately
rook a to the 8 and now what do you do
here you have to move the Queen Fischer
played Queen captures on b7 and now
comes Queen to e3 check
Fischer played King to f1 and here
Larsson played rock the b2 so here in
this position Larsson is of course
threatening Queen to F - checkmate how
do you prevent this well there is only
one move that prevents it or as it seems
prolongs it Queen to c6 check ok
you gave a check but what now Larsson
blocks check rook to e6 so now your
queen is under attack and also Larsson
is still threatening Queen to have to
checkmate so how do you how do you save
the Queen and prevent checkmate but this
is the position Fischer saw when he
decided to sacrifice the exchange with
rook captures on e5 pause the video here
and try to finger figure out a way out
of this mess you know try to see what
Fischer saw before he even sacrificed
the rock on e5 I'll give you a couple of
seconds if you want to decide whether
you do it or not
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you truly are an
excellent player and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
if you found Queen to c5 then you would
not be winning game number one in this
match
you would instead lose it in in a
terrible way here look - f2 would have
been played and this comes with check
your only move is king to g1 and now
comes route captures on f3
this comes with a discovered check you
have to capture the Queen Queen captures
rook captures and now you have two rooks
against a rook and the bishop and the
white position is so bad that black
would win this easily but after this
rook to e6 move if you have found Bishop
to c5 then you are truly an excellent
player and this is the move Fischer
played and this is the move Fischer saw
when he played that rook captures on e5
move so what happens here well here's
the problem of course if you play rook
captures Bishop captures then you
haven't really done anything to bishops
and the rocker
then two rooks a white would be winning
here but what happens with rook 2f to
check well this is what Fisher had in
mind King the g1 and now rook captures
on f3 doesn't work because of the simple
Bishop captures on e3 now rook captures
on c6 and now G captures on f3 you have
a bishop and the rook against the rook
so Fischer is up a piece easily winning
after this kink the g1 move of course
rook captures and g2 was played and now
opening up a double attack against
Fischer scheme and here you you might
well of course you don't want to play
king of one you dare to look to g1
checkmate but what happens if you play
King to h1 if King to h1 then comes rook
captures on h2 King captures and Queen
to d2 check King moves and now Luke
captures on c6 Bishop captures and Queen
captures on c3 the rook is under attack
on a1 you have to move it with tempo if
you're ever to capture the a summon
point so the problem is after rook to g1
check King to f7 you get rook to g2 you
don't have time to capture the a7 pawn
this is basically the whole plan Fisher
Fisher had because there's the Queen to
h3 checkmate threat so first you have to
stop this
and then after Queen e1 check Bishop the
g1 black goes g5 and black is much
faster White will no longer be able to
win the a7 pawn and black will in the
end win this game
so after this rook captures on g2 a
Fisher doesn't go H 1 f1 rather he
captures the Road King captures on g2
now comes Queen to d2 with check King to
h1 and rook captures on c6 we have
Bishop captures on c6 and Queen captures
on c3 attacking Fisher's rook like in
the position we just discussed we have
rook to g1 check King moves but now the
the poet the pawn is on h2 so there is
no threat of Queen - which three
checkmate Bishop captures on a7 is
possible and now we have this amazing
position where Fischer has a rook and
two bishops
and when both of these bishops go back
for example Bishop g2 and the bishop to
f1 then they will be able to escort
a point up the board so what can Larsen
do about this well of course one thing
we have to ask ourselves whether he will
go for Queen captures on c2 if he does
go for this of course he now created a
passed pawn of his own so he wants to
push it as well so let's see how this
could go a five Queen to d3 starting
making room for the past C pawn a six
and now c3 Bishop to b7 you have to
guard the a6 pawn before you can move
the dark square bishop and prepare to
push it
c2 we have Bishop to b6 and now what can
you do if you play Queen to d1 this will
not really work you can simply push a 7
and after characters captures white
black does get a queen but white now has
a queen and two bishop so obviously this
mate doesn't really make much sense but
on the other hand after this Queen
Bishop to b6 move Queen to b5 is an idea
attacking the dark square Bishop Bishop
moves now comes King e6 but now this
rook to e1 check comes King d6 and now
Bishop the g1 and now the pawn is ready
to be escorted King to c7 now comes Rock
to c1 attacking the pawn queen going to
be too
now comes a rook captures Queen captures
and Bishop goes back but here you would
again be able to escort the pawn of the
board and wouldn't really wouldn't
really work so capturing and starting to
push her C pawn doesn't seem to work
just yet so here a Larson played the g5
he wants to discord innate display the
the bishops are protecting the King but
also Fischer's bishops will be used to
escort to the point D a pawn of the
board so Larson has to get somehow this
f4 g4 and f3 and perhaps then he will be
able to create some counter play here
Fischer finds the only move that makes
that allows white to push for advantage
so again feel free to pause the video
here you don't have to do it for a very
long time just you have this position on
the board Larson just played g5 what do
you play here I'll give it a couple of
seconds as usual so for those of you who
were able to do it and if you found the
answer to the first challenge and this
one as well and then you are by all
means an excellent player
and for those of you who might just want
to enjoy the show here Fischer played
Bishop to b6 and this is the only move
if you tried something else for example
of course you all know that you have to
move the bishop to start pushing your
passport now what if you move it's 2 F 2
then Queen chapters on c2 now black
created passport but this comes with
tempo your Bishop is now under attack if
instead of Bishop to b6 you try Bishop
to c5 again it's not all that great you
will not be able to push your pawn
because the FF square is not guarded by
the bishop anymore so push up the b6 the
strongest move we have Queen to c2
capturing the pawn and now a5 Fischer
simply starts pushing his past pawn
Queen B - now of course you cannot push
the pawn because your Bishop will be
under attacked so rush up to d8 with
check this is a very interesting move
into e6 and now a6 Queen to a3 not
allowing the pawn to be pushed any
further Bishop to b7 simply blocking so
what can Larsson do here if he pushes c3
then again rook to e1 comes with check
King b7 and now Bishop to b6 now we have
c2 and simply a7 start pushing his
passport we have Queen rook captures
Queen captures Bishop goes back and
again there is no way to stop promotion
of da pawn so here after Bishop to b7
Larsen tried Queen to c5 but now comes
the move Fischer planned rook to be 1
preparing to bring the bishop over to b6
and it doesn't matter what you do here
if you try Queen a7 you will still get
Bishop to b6 Queen is under attack
pusher b8
now you will move the bishop bishop d4
and you will simply move your pawn and
win the game
for example Queen f4 a7 is coming and
there's nothing to do here so I have to
look to be 1 Larson tried c3 but here
first simply played Bishop to b6 and it
was in this position that Larson decided
to resign the game because the two
bishops are simply too [ __ ] too
powerful two bishops combined they
cannot be opposed there are they are
much better than a queen because the
Queen only hits one in one direction
while the bishops slice two diagonals in
both ways so the bishops are guarding
the King
while also guarding the the promote the
the promotion square and the squares
that will escort the point of the board
so a truly amazing game and it's really
it really shows that how how Fischer
outclassed Larsen in game number one
because at this moment where were
Fischer prepared everything you know the
scene was ready and he played that after
King to g6 Larsen thought okay
everything is everything is ok here
whatever he plays I was simply simply I
don't know play Bishop c6 exchange
pieces everything will be fine
Fischer finds this rook captures an e5
and it was probably you know who knows
how long before this row captors on e5
move Fisher actually saw this Bishop to
c5 Queen c6 check roadblocks Bishop to
c5 only move that stops checkmate and
allows Fischer to push for advantage so
I mean truly an amazing game and if you
remember Fisher Fisher had 7 consecutive
wins by the end of Palma de Majorca
inter-zonal tournament in 1970 then in
1971 when the can have in quarterfinals
started he defeated marked him on off
with 6 to 0 so that's 13 consecutive
wins and this is the first game he's
playing against bent Larsen in his
semi-final match so that's already 14
consecutive wins but you know we didn't
name the series Fischer's legendary
streak for no reason so the streak still
continues so yeah
this video was a bit longer but it's
only the first game in the series you
know so we had to say something more
about the match I do hope you enjoyed
that as well like I said check out the
link in the description below a lot more
interesting stuff about the match will
be there so do check it out I would like
to thank Michael declare Benjamin
Davidson Davidson Robert Stratford and
the Davos rice for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon
most likely continuing the Fisher series
and you know I really I really do hope
hope you enjoyed it I think you'll and
I'll see you soon